dozens of people have been killed in an
explosion at a political rally in
Northwest Pakistan it happened in the
Bajaj District bordering Afghanistan
ambulances are arriving at the site as a
large contingent of police cordon off
the area let's go to Kamal Haider in
islamaban Kamal what does the aftermath
look like
well it doesn't look good at all because
the death toll is rising continuously we
are told that over a hundred are now
wounded at least 25 kills but that
figure may go up very soon according to
the sources that we have spoken to now
as you mentioned budget is near the
Afghan border about 260 kilometers from
Islamabad and there have been
apprehensions that perhaps
the tarika Taliban Pakistan may be
involved but it's important to note that
at this convention there was a senator
from the Jamaica Islam it was their
workers convention
there was a member of parliament there
also one of the local leaders in bajawar
was also is reported to have been killed
a senior cameraman for a local network
is wounded and most of the Wounded of
course have been rushed to peshavo which
is a provincial capital that's at least
three hours away don't we'd be the
wounded with serious injuries now it's
also important to note that the party is
headed by Maulana father Rahman he's a
part of the coalition government which
is known as the Pakistan Democratic
Alliance and he enjoys considerably poor
support and the kind of type of Pokemon
Province so indeed an explosion we don't
know whether this was an explosive
device whether this was a suicide bomber
too early to predict that but indeed the
death toll has been rising and there are
apprehensions that it could rise
significantly all right we'll come back
to you a little bit later come we've got
more details on that